[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
laurent marc angeli bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
député de la corse-du-sud président du
groupe horizon à l'assemblée nationale
cette partie d'edouard philippe et vous
étiez jusqu'à votre élection maire
d'ajaccio on va être ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest-france boulons ses fans
lors marc angeli hier on a vu l'élection
de yaël brune piger première femme à
occuper ce poste et dont son discours
elle a parlé de sa vision de l'assemblée
l'assemblée qui devra selon elle plutôt
débattre que deux se bat ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir un vrai changement de
méthode oui je l'ait déjà plaidée devant
la première ministre il ya deux jours
les français nous ont donné une
assemblée qui a nous amène à repenser
notre mode de fonctionnement d'abord en
interne les députés à doivent travailler
je le pense autrement pas de majorité
absolue une multitude de groupes très
éloignées parfois les uns des autres et
ensuite je crois que le gouvernement va
devoir s'il veut que les textes passent
à voir une nouvelle méthode pour
préparer la loi et je crois également
que la première ministre a bien compris
qu'en plus elle écoute fusent à l'écouté
de l'opposition plus à l'écouté plus
dans la co construction je me souviens
il ya quelques années jean françois copé
a quand il était président du groupe ump
demandé la co-construction législatives
mais à l'époque il y avait une majorité
absolue très importante là je crois que
les français ont décidé à deux nous lui
faire faire à marche forcée vous pas ce
que ça veut dire que les députés de la
majorité devront prendre leur part aussi
changer d'attitude vis-à-vis de
l'opposition aux scouts tout le monde
doit s'y mettre moi je vais en tout cas
c'est ce que je dis à mon groupe nous
devons nous tenir compte de ce que les
français on dit et votre attitude doit
pas être une attitude de des dames
vis-à-vis des oppositions vous
travaillez avec eux s'ils en ont envie
moi en tout cas je serai un président de
groupe qui tendra la main aux autres
groupes pour essayer de contrer toutes
les oppositions parce que emmanuel
macron il exclut le rassemblement
national il exclut la france en serbie
c'est ce que vous dites il faut qu'on
parle à tout mais opposition parler
c'est nécessaire et je crois que si
demain le groupe de monsieur mélenchon
va me dire que nous sommes au mois de
juin je vais pas pour le plaisir de dire
que je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui
mentir donc il y aura peut-être des
amendements qui viendront de la nu ps
qui seront frappés du coin du bon sens
et j'ai même allé jusqu'à dire que sur
certains textes pouvait avoir des
amendements portés par le rn qui a
peuvent améliorer la loi gens qu'il va
falloir qu'on soit très pragmatique
qu'on sorte des postures idéologiques et
concise une chose c'est que le confort
de la majorité absolue n'est pas acquis
et ne sera pas acquis à mon avis durant
cette mandature ou 18 ans de la main
propre au temps de la main où je prends
mes votre expression littéralement au
pied de la lettre est-ce que vous avez
vu hier à la tribune vous aviez un des
six jeunes députés assesseurs qui
refusait de serrer la main des députés
assurent leur nationale j'ai connu ça
bizarre oui j'ai dit que vous avez vous
même été assesseur lalanne
impressionnèrent il ya dix ans j'étais
au bureau d'âge avec marion maréchal-le
pen est incertain députés avaient refusé
de lui serrer la main je n'aime pas ça
je vous le dis très tranquillement vous
étiez députés en 2 min 11 ans voilà je
n'aime pas ça parce que ne pas serrer la
main de quelqu'un lorsqu'on est dans une
institution est que nous sommes tous
égaux pour une bonne et simple raison
c'est que nous représentons tous une
part de la souveraineté populaire à
travers le vote s'est pas forcément ma
manière de concevoir la vie politique on
peut combattre quelqu'un mais quand même
lui serrer la main un dernier mot sur ce
qu'il s'est passé hier avant de revenir
aux consultations d'elisabeth baume le
doyen âge de l'assemblée a prononcé un
discours il est membre du rassemblement
national josé gonzalez et il a évoqué
son cas personnel il les pieds-noirs né
à oran il a évoqué sa terre natale à
laquelle elle a été arrachée at il dit
j'ai laissé là bas une partie de ma
frange faisant référence à
l'indépendance de l'algérie qu'avez vous
pensé de ces propos moi c'est un vieux
débat vous savez
moi je suis dans la compassion par
rapport à celles et ceux qui sont encore
vivants et qui ont vécu ce drame moi
j'ai trouvé globalement que le discours
elle était plutôt sobre et qu'il n'a pas
profité de cette tribune pour partir
dans des un mauvais chemin il a parlé de
lui la présidente de l'assemblée a
beaucoup parlé de sa situation
personnelle et familiale également
c'était l'occasion pour lui de le faire
et je pense que c'est pas forcément
quelque chose de scandaleux
choqué une partie des députés de gauche
pour vous c'est exagéré ou tc sont les
discours mémoriel je suis toujours très
prudent lorsqu'il s'agit d'évoquer
l'histoire dans les arènes politiques on
va revenir aux discussions puisque vous
l'avez dit vous avez rencontré elizabeth
bornes c'était lundi
lord qui consulte actuellement les
présidents de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale pour tenter de trouver une
majorité qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit
vous je lui ai dit que d'abord il était
certainement préférable d'aller chercher
le vote de confiance parce que si elle
ne le fait pas je pense que des motions
de censure peuvent être déposés et que
de toute manière le débat aura lieu sur
un vote de confiance ou pas vis-à-vis du
gouvernement
je vous ai dit allez prête parce que
elle semble hésiter elle n'a pas donné
de réponse mais elle a écouté l'argument
ensuite je lui ai dit ce que je viens de
vous dire c'est à dire qu'on va devoir
travailler d'une autre manière que même
si nous plaidons nous continuerons de
plaider pour une coalition qui semble
plus difficile à atteindre que nous nous
respirer il va falloir travailler avec
l'ensemble des groupes plus
spécifiquement avec certains d'un truc
qui se revendique comme étant des partis
de gouvernement disons le très
clairement mais parce que les
républicains avec la pluie a pu aussi on
a parlé de la situation du pays parce
que je crois qu'à on oublie quand même
que le colis de repart que les taux
d'intérêt sont très très haut que nous
avons une voix très importante sur le
pouvoir d'achat l'être contre
l'inflation qui doit être présenté au
parlement qui va être un texte et en
parler fondamentale est que il ya quand
même une grosse angoisse dans le pays à
travers tous ces problèmes que nous
vivons depuis plusieurs années donc on a
parlé de ça aussi quand vous suggérer la
première ministre de demander un vote de
confiance vous êtes vous êtes sûr que ça
passerait en l'état actuel des choses à
un risque qui est une commune de
commencer cette législature par un
événement politique qui serait pas
forcément de bonne augure je pense que
nous avons un début de réponse hier à
travers la manière dont l'élection de la
présidente de l'assemblée nationale
s'est passé je pense pas aujourd'hui que
les différents groupes de l'assemblée
nationale souhaite la crise souhaitent
le blocage de nos institutions
souhaitent la stabilité
on peut très bien s'abstenir sur un vote
de confiance au paddock et l'institution
on n'est pas obligé de voter pour ou
contre on peut aussi voté pour
alors que à la base on n'est pas
forcément un député ou une députée de la
majorité présidentielle les exemples
sont nombreux ils l'avaient a été
d'ailleurs de même il ya cinq ans sur le
vote de confiance du premier
gouvernement d'edouard philippe donc moi
je crois que j'ai fait juste que
sébastien chenu le candidat du
rassemblement national se soient retirés
pour permettre l'élection
nationale
pour vous c'est bon signe sur le fait
qu'il ya une volonté d'opposition
constructive je pense aujourd'hui que
parler du rrn n'a pas brillé en disant
nous voulons bloquer l'institution nous
voulons faire en sorte que plus rien ne
fonctionne après c'est à la première
ministre de décider d'autres premiers
ministres avant elle ont fait le choix
de ne pas demander le vote de confiance
moi j'ai été consulté et j'ai donné la
vie qui est le mien et je pense qu'il
serait de bon ton de le demander est ce
que vous êtes dans les échanges qu'il a
eus avec des abbesses bande est ce que
vous avez quelques informations
concernant le futur remaniement
gouvernemental non est ce que ça va
donner je ne sais pas ce que ça va
donner puisque cela appartient à la
première ministre au président de la
république en revanche j'ai donné mon
avis je considère que nous avons
les des points paroisse si vous me
permettez de le dire aurizon a un très
bon mix délégué aux collectivités
territoriales qui christophe béchu je
pense que d'abord il doit rester au
gouvernement parce que sa noble de
qualité mais que nous avons également en
réserve un certain nombre de
personnalités qui pourraient être au
gouvernement tombe ou dont moi je n'ai
pas à plaider pour moi je pense qu'il ya
à côté de moi dans ce parti politique
des femmes et des hommes
particulièrement qualifié pour être de
bons ministres elisabeth dont elle
cherche un accord de gouvernement est ce
que ces discussions ne sont pas un peu
vaine avec l'opposition est ce qu'un
accord du gouvernement vous semblez
allant possible aujourd'hui on s'oriente
plus sur le texte par texte que sur la
coalition signé devant les français
témoins comme on peut le voir dans
d'autres démocraties c'est ça vous sont
tenables une majorette être experte ex
sur le long terme sur les cinq ans cet
inédit nous allons voir si à nos
institutions qui sont tout de même
remarquable sont capables d'absorber ce
choix des français que nous devons
respecter et dont les discussions sont
jamais vesle parce que je crois que les
français le 19 juin dernier ils ont
demandé au gouvernement ils ont demandé
aux parlementaires d'agir ainsi
vous êtes issu des républicains de m
on a parlé tout à l'heure est ce que
vous les appelez à rejoindre emmanuel
macron comme l'a fait hier gérald
darmanin moi je les appelle à être ce
qu'ils sont c'est à dire un parti à la
base qui a vocation à gouverner ce pays
a pas être dans une attitude
d'opposition systématique à être dans
une attitude de co construction est ce
que je peux leur dire dès aujourd'hui
c'est que si les propositions qu'ils
font dans le cadre de la fabrique de la
loi bon dans un sens qui nous paraît
positif nous n'aurons aucune raison de
leur dire non le choix le choix
d'olivier marne ex comme président du
groupe parlementaire les républicains
c'est pas forcément un signe d'ouverture
vis-à-vis vous avez du pouvoir c'est un
choix qui appartient au groupe allait
avait pu blique un mois j'ai pas a
commenté le seul commentaire que je peux
faire c'est le choix des députés
horizons et il me plaît beaucoup puisque
j'ai été très bien reçue par les
collègues mais sur olivier mallet que
certains députés expérimentés c'est vrai
que c'est une personnalité qui a fait
savoir un certain nombre de désaccords
profonds qu'ils avaient bataillé ferme
contre le président avec le président de
la république mais là on parle de
fabrique de la loi et de rapports avec
le gouvernement je vous rappelle que
dans la constitution de la vème
république ou bien la relire il ya le
président qui préside il ya le premier
ministre a pris hier 10 qui gouverne et
à l'assemblée qui légifèrent messieurs
se met à la place des républicains
aujourd'hui quel est l'intérêt des
républicains de vous rejoindre et de
travailler avec vous est ce que leurs
électeurs ne leur ont pas donné mandat
d'être dans l'opposition tête intérêts
de la france ceci 1 je crois que les
républicains sont patriotes qui le
souhaitent la stabilité institutionnelle
ils sont héritiers à tout comme je pense
l'être à 2 ans celui qui a fondé notre
système politique le général de gaulle
et je pense que lorsqu'on est un
gaulliste ou issus de cette famille
politique on n'est pas forcément les
apôtres de la pagaille et du désordre et
surtout il ya surtout les français je
pense mais mais ils doivent rester pour
vous ils doivent rester un parti ancré
les républicains partis d'opposition et
travailler avec vous où vous dites fini
les républicains il faut qu'on travaille
tous ensemble il faut qu'ils nous
rejoignent non je me permettrais pas de
dire ça à moi ce que je pense c'est que
il faut qu'il soit utile dans leur
mandat en respectant les engagements
qu'ils ont pris et comme nous ne pouvons
pas nous le savons aujourd'hui dérouler
notre programme présidentiel s'en aller
négocier sans aller faire des compromis
pas des compromissions il faut que nous
apprenions dans ce pays l'art du
compromis politique nos voisins
européens sont très féru je crois que
c'est une nouvelle et peut-être même une
bonne nouvelle pour le pays qu'il en
soit ainsi le problème c'est que c'est
notre culture politique est très
différente de celle de nos voisins on
est nous rapport demandé seconde est
beaucoup dans des moutons du rapport de
force et de l'opposition frontale dans
la manière de faire de la politique dans
ce pays s comment est ce que les
républicains ou douze formations
politiques pourraient se rapprocher du
gouvernement ou du pouvoir sans donner
l'impression de trahir ses électeurs
parce que c'est souvent ça le point qui
fait que finalement chacun campe sur ses
positions et imaginer un texte de loi ou
un certain nombre d'amendements sont
retenus émanant de ce groupe ou d'un
autre il faut aller expliquer aux gens
pourquoi est ce qu'on a obtenu que les
amendements soient passés du coût final
on vote contre le texte faut un peu de
cohérence et je crois que le
gouvernement devra davantage en amont
préparer tenir compte des amendements de
l'opposition j'ai d'abord en amont des
textes avant de les présenter consulter
davantage et ensuite aussi de tenir
compte davantage d un moment parce que
dans un passé récent je parle au karité
plutôt systématique de rejeté les
amendements des oppositions et parmi les
premiers textes le premier texte qui
sera examiné par l'assemblée nationale
16 sur le pouvoir d'achat un texte qui
arrive au mont bruno le maire alerte sur
l'état des finances publiques il a eu
raison de faire sa déclaration
bien sûr je crois qu'il faut dire la
vérité aux français nous avons vécu une
période particulièrement
inédite où le gouvernement est venu en
renfort de notre économie avec beaucoup
d'affection d'argent public et
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à un
effet ciseau nous avons nos finances
publiques qui sont dans un état dégradé
et inquiétant une dette qui continuent
de courir et qui pose la question de
notre souveraineté économique et
financière et ensuite vous avez la
problématique des taux d'intérêt qui
doit quand même alerté fortement
l'ensemble des dirigeants et l'ensemble
des parlementaires faut être responsable
et je crois que le ministre de
l'économie et des finances a rappelé un
certain nombre de réalités que nous
devons tous avoir à l'esprit mais est-ce
qu'on peut dans le même temps annoncé
autant de mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat
est ce que c'est pas un peu incompatible
c'est toute la difficulté de l'exercice
dans lequel nous nous trouvons en même
temps nous ne tenons pas compte
aujourd'hui de ce qui se passe dans des
millions de foyers français avec
l'incapacité pour nos concitoyens de
payer leur plein d'essence ou tout
simplement de faire leur plein de
courses je crois qu'on va être
complètement à côté du sujet d'ailleurs
moi je considère que la problématique du
pouvoir d'achat et de la lutte contre
l'inflation est aujourd'hui la première
des priorités montre mieux les cibler
ces mesures l'examen des textes qui vont
être présentés par le gouvernement nous
permettra je le pense d'avoir des débats
riches à l'assemblée nationale lors
l'augmentation des salaires des
fonctionnaires de 3
5% c'est aussi une bonne nouvelle le
problème c'est comment qui finance
commence et les collectivités locales
est ce que sont el hombre vont avoir les
moyens notamment je ne vais pas vous
cacher que je reste encore maire puisque
j'ai pas encore les fonds dits
démissionné et que l'augmentation à 3,5
pour cent me pose un certain nombre de
questions lorsque je regarde je fais le
focus sur à mes frais de personnel sur
la ville d'ajaccio pensée pour
l'ensemble des mères il va falloir des
mécanismes de compensation parce que je
peux vous dire a d'ores et déjà que pour
ce qui concerne la ville dont j'ai
l'honneur d'être le premier magistrat
pour l'heure ça va être difficile donc
ça veut dire que ce n'était pas une
bonne nouvelle il aurait fallu consulter
les collectivités avant d'annoncer une
nouvelle pour les
forêts fallu les consulter avant
d'annoncer une hausse générale des
du salaire des fonctionnaires je pense
que la discussion est toujours
préférable et que peut-être n'at-elle
pas été suffisamment poussées en tout
cas je peux dire aujourd'hui ce sera
difficile à soutenir donc il faudra des
mécanismes de composer des compensations
plus généralement de la décompensation
pour les salaires des fonctionnaires on
sait que les collectivités ont aussi du
mal à faire face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie évidemment elles sont
impactées par cette hausse est ce que là
aussi il faut des mesures
supplémentaires parce que les
particuliers sont aidés mais pas les
collectivités pas seulement pas
seulement l'énergie mais également les
matériaux parce que je vous rappelle
aujourd'hui vous a voté un
investissement quels qu'ils soient des
travaux vous n'êtes pas sûr d'avoir le
même prix du matériel dans une semaine
ou deux et donc les avenants sont
nombreux aujourd'hui dans les
collectivités mais bien sûr qu'il va
falloir aussi tenir compte de
l'inflation pour les collectivités qui
sont l'émanation de l'intérêt public et
général qui concourt au bien commun
quotidiennement donc oui je pense que
dans les discussions avec les
collectivités qui vont être très
importants de sa discussion parce
qu'elles n'ont pas toujours été si
simple que ça eh bien il faudra quand
même tenir compte de cette situation qui
pèse sur leur économie
va falloir que les collectivités fassent
des économies ou à titre personnel j'en
ai réalisé je sais que les maires
présidents de département et président
de région font beaucoup d'efforts mais
il va falloir aussi a toujours je pense
avoir ce dialogue et à voir la
compréhension de ce qui se passe dans
nos territoires et dans nos
collectivités dans le contexte
économique difficile que vous que vous
décrivez contenu toutes ces tensions est
ce qu'il est raisonnable ou est ce qu'il
pense et de continuer à prôner à le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite ce qu'il faut pas amender le
projet est ce que c'est le bon moment
alors d'abord sur le projet il ya eu
plusieurs
versions pendant la campagne
présidentielle et pendant la campagne
législative c'est une thématique a
beaucoup crispé aussi je le sais je les
ai vus dans ma circonscription c'était
là dessus sur lequel j'étais attaqué et
moins ce qui me concerne je crois qu'il
faut faire preuve de pragmatisme
étant donné que nous avons une assemblée
nationale qui n'était pas celle qu'on
attendait et donc c'est un texte majeur
qu'il va falloir négocier avec les
partenaires sociaux mais également au
sein de l'hémicycle et avec le sénat
on sait qu'elle adore philippines était
très attaché à ce report de l'âge de
dette lui il a même parlé 65-66 voire 67
ans s qu'horizon pourra voter un texte
une réforme des retraites s'il n'y a pas
de report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite ils devraient pas fonctionner
par totem je vous le dis très
tranquillement pourquoi parce que
horizon justement nous avons vocation à
avoir une vision de la politique qui
n'est pas celle qu'on a pu voir pendant
quelques années où on se crispe où on
crie parce qu'on n'est pas content on va
tranquillement examiner ce qui sera
proposé
dans philippe avait évoqué tout 67 ans
pourquoi parce que c'est l'âge de départ
à la retraite dans beaucoup de pays
voisins qui ont sauvé leurs systèmes par
ce truchement ensuite nous allons
attendre ce que le gouvernement va
proposer
c'est un des gros sujets de ce
quinquennat et je pense que l'assemblée
nationale va avoir un rôle prépondérant
dans la confection de cette loi en tout
cas moi je vais militer fortement pour
que nous prenions tout autre part en
tant que groupe horizon mais je crois
que l'assemblée dans son ensemble va
avoir un rôle prépondérant mais si on
disait tout à l'heure que 65 ans était
jeune âge qui crispe lequel beaucoup
crispé 67 ans c'est inimaginable
ça sera très difficile à mon avis de
proposer 67 ans mais moi encore une fois
c'était un article une interview qu
edouard philippe a fait il ya quelques
mois dans un autre contexte politique où
il a dit 65 66 ou 67
il n'a pas dit 67 et rien d'autre il a
juste ouvert des perspectives de
réflexion dans une période où nous
n'étions pas forcément dans la même
situation si je trouve que permettre de
rappeler ce qui s'est passé au mois
d'octobre c'était à ce moment là qu'il a
dit cela nous sommes au mois de juin je
crois que la situation économique
financière et sociale du pays n'est pas
totalement la même justement vous dites
horizon on a pas de telle quelle est
votre vision de ce que doit être le
groupe horizon est ce que vous serez un
partenaire loyal cas quoiqu'il arrive
est ce que vous serez un partenaire
exigeant quitte à ne pas voter comme le
comprenez sens moi je le jure j'exclus
déjà la crise
et le non vote et le rejet de vote ne
seront loyaux nous l'avons toujours dit
et je pense que bien malin celui qui
arriverait à démontrer que nous avons
été dans la déloyauté dans les campagnes
de l'élection du président dans la
campagne législative et dans chacune des
interventions d'edouard philippe
quinault de président la loyauté c'est
notre marque de fabrique ensuite c'est
le travail votre marque de fabrique on a
envie d'être actif treize ans côté du
gouvernement force de proposition sur
les textes qui sont tout près ceux qui
vont arriver immédiatement mais
également sur la vision stratégique de
notre pays a pour aller à 30 prochaines
années parce que je pense que ce serait
pas de trop d'avoir une vraie vision
stratégique et c'est justement l'une des
marques de fabrique de notre parti et
puis pour conclure je dirais que nous
avons ici une petite spécificité nous
sommes ancrés dans les territoires nous
avons beaucoup d'élus locaux qui a sont
dans notre parti et je crois que ça peut
ben oui les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes
beaucoup de maires de responsables
publics locaux et je crois que ça peut
aider le gouvernement à s'enraciner et
la majorité à s'enraciner dans nos
territoires comment les choses ont
fonctionné entre autres vous votre
groupe parlementaire et edouard philippe
justement est ce que le dialogue sera
très régulier comment comment vous allez
fonctionner au quotidien pendant les
cinq ans qui viennent par rapport à lui
qui a choisi de rester maire du havre et
parle pas de prêtre ne pas devenir
redevenir député il est président d'un
parti qui est à très lié à ce groupe et
son avis est toujours le bienvenu mais
le groupe c le groupe el parti c'est le
parti pour moi qui l'ait dit c'est lui
qui l'a dit lors du bureau politique que
nous avons eu hier il est très
respectueux des prérogatives des uns et
des autres edouard philippe dans une
envisagé pas de l'inviter à chaque
réunion de groupe il y est toujours le
bienvenu d'abord ça défoule avait
systématiquement
l'ifi pensé le faire avec jean luc
mélenchon déficit d'une invitation
permanente mais je pense qu'il ne
viendra pas chaque mardi à nos réunions
parce que considère que le groupe doit
avoir sa propre vie d'ailleurs je dois
préciser que tous les membres du groupe
ne sont pas des reins horizon ses
horizons et apparentés vous et 12
apparentés voilà ce qu'il n'a pas
intérêt et dans le fim est passé mon psy
ped emmanuel macron en 2027 vous savez
on sort à peine d'un tunnel électorale
qu'on voudrait déjà penser à l'élection
présidentielle et on voudrait déjà pensé
à d'éventuelles élections législatives
anticipées je crois qu'il va falloir
qu'on s'habitue non mais on sait qu
emmanuel macron pourra pas se
représenter en 2027 je le donne et on
imagine qu'il doit affiner pas quand
même envie se représenter même s'il ne
le dit pas est-ce qu'il n'a pas intérêt
à s'émanciper des manuels macron vu ce
qu'a donné la présidentielle jusqu'en
jeunes et jc hâtives mais je crois qu'il
doit flipper d'un homme particulièrement
libres et émancipées ça n'a échappé à
personne il est maire d'une grande ville
métropole il est président d'un parti
politique qui a fait élire 30 députés
alors qu'il n'avait que 58 candidats
enregistrés au départ c'est pas mal
comme ratio ce qui lui donne en plus
accessoirement des moyens en terme de
financement public de deux parties pour
les cinq ans à venir évidemment il ya
aussi cette donnée qui doit être prise
en compte mais je crois que ne parlons
pas trop des échéances de 2027 on a
quand même suffisamment ne travaille pas
sur la planche en fin de semaine et de
mois mais il les prépare un plan quand
même
où nous parlons au risque de vous
surprendre
au risque de vous surprendre les nanas
fois que je les bus étaient hier on n'a
pas parlé des présidentielles de 2000 26
ans après on a parlé de la situation un
peu difficile dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons et jeter un dernier mot puisque
on parle d'une situation difficile la
situation sanitaire à risque d'être à
nouveau difficile dans les prochains
jours les quatre qu'ovide remontent
fortement hier le tribunal administratif
a mis en cause l'état pour ne pas avoir
fait de stocks suffisants de masque
avant l'épidémie mais surtout en
laissant penser que le port du masque et
est inutile c'est à dire il juge que la
communication gouvernementale n'a pas
été la bonne ça c'est un coup dur pour
edouard philippe
c'est pas une condamnation jouer bien
préciser il faut bien lire la décision
de justice les de l'avs
tu as est mise en cause mais en fait le
tribunal considère que l'état a fait une
erreur une erreur et ce qui est rappelé
et il faut quand même se replonger à
deux ans et demi en arrière c'est le
manque de connaissance de cette maladie
au moment où ces décisions ont été
prises et surtout le caractère
éminemment aléatoire de la transmission
de cette maladie vous le voyez encore
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui sont
dans le même temps de même foyer une
personne qui l'a l'autre qui l'a pas
c'était ça dès le début avec également
je crois manque de connaissances du
moment donc non ce n'est pas un coup dur
c'est injuste le fait est là
remontrances de l'état elles portent sur
le fait que les stocks n'étaient des
deux masques étaient inexistants ou pas
un niveau et par passion pas sur
l'emploi ou l'endoctrinement fait mais
il est rappelé également dans la
décision que les masques ce noeud
n'assure pas forcément la
non-contamination donc et c'est
démontrer scientifiquement qu'on peut
attraper le coc vide avec des masques
c'est un vaste sujet une dernière
question qui attend encore maire
d'ajaccio on imagine que vous allez
continuer à vous occuper du dossier
corse gérald darmanin avait promis des
consultations avec les élus de l'île
avec jean simmons elle ne chante pas eu
lieu et ce qu'elles doivent se tenir
rapidement je pense que il faut discuter
pour assurer à la corse ce que j'appelle
de mes voeux depuis de nombreuses années
un dialogue apaisé pacifique avec l'état
basé sur le travail le projet et une
vision pour la corse et à l'avenir de
ses enfants
c'est là dessus que je me battrai il
faut qu'elles aient lieu avant l'été oui
bien sûr il faut une prise de contact
pour définir une méthode et moi
j'apporterai mon concours modestement
mais avec beaucoup de détermination
merci laurent martin dias merci beaucoup
de nous horizon à l'assemblée nationale
et encore maire d'ajaccio pour au moins
quelques jours merci d'avoir été notre
invité
[Musique]